bonjour jean françois corty merci d'être
avec nous cet après midi sur rt france
alors on la vit un tout à l'heure elle
les partenaires sociaux et les syndicats
se réunissent aujourd'hui pour parler
justement ce protocole de déconfinement
avec elle cette question la question du
port du masque obligatoire en entreprise
faut-il imposer ce port du masque
écoutez ce qui est important c'est de
prendre des décisions de ce type c'est
de bien revenir sur la situation les
indicateurs se dégrade
on l'a rappelé une augmentation près de
2500 nouveaux cas en moins de 24 heures
à ce que veut dire que le virus est
actif dans plusieurs régions et
notamment ile-de-france les bouches du
rhône avec un taux d'incidence qui a
dépassé les seuils d'alerté c'est à dire
au delà de 50 pour cent mille habitants
ce qui veut dire que l'épidémie elle est
active et les rapides dans sa
propagation donc il faut être vigilant
et il faut appliquer des mesures pour
contenir le risque est dans notre
démocratie sanitaire il ya deux acteurs
principaux la société civile à et vocaux
qui doit respecter les gestes barrière
qui doit toujours avoir conscience du
danger qui doit ne pas hésiter à les
faire tester sur n'importe quel signe
potentiellement évocateur du duc au vide
et puis il y à l'état qui doit prendre
continuer à prendre ses responsabilités
que ce soit en accentuant les remontant
le nombre de deux sites on peut se faire
dépister
que ce soit en consolidant les équipes
de terrain qui vont tester isolé allait
enquêter pour retrouver les patients qui
seraient malades sans le savoir
et évidemment la question du masque est
un point central de mon point de vue on
le sait bien l'épidémie repart du fait
de nombreux cluster soient liés à des
regroupements familiaux soient liés aux
professionnels en milieu hospitalier en
ehpad en entreprise
de fait de mon point de vue il va
falloir accentuer l'utilisation du
masque notamment en entreprise où cela
n'est pas encore obligatoire
jean françois corty vous le lisiez à
l'instant le
le nombre de personnes contaminées au
coronavirus repart à la hausse de 1500
en 24 heures comment on peut on peut
expliquer cette augmentation du nombre
de contaminés un relâchement de la
population il ya plusieurs déterminant
qui sont mis en avant le fait qu'il y
ait relâchement des mesures de
confinement évidemment avec une
augmentation des lieux de regroupement
encore une fois que ce soit des moments
festifs familiaux avec des risques de
contamination
aussi dans des dents dans les milieux
confinés
de mon point de vue ce qui est ce qui
est important c'est de rappeler certes
qu'il faut être vigilant on sait que
c'est là la catégorie des 14 de 44 ans
qui aujourd'hui est le plus impacté par
cette dégradation des indicateurs même
si les personnes âgées qui sont à risque
sont aussi toujours touché ce qui est
fondamental c'est de faire en sorte que
lorsqu'on est en bonne santé et que l'on
doit aller rendre visite à notre famille
a des parents à des gens fragiles à des
grands parents on fait attention on
continue à mettre le mas à se laver les
mains et à la protéger selon m et puis
évidemment encore une fois quand on est
à la tête de l'état on fait en sorte
qu'ils aient un accès inconditionnel au
masque de mon point de vue il faudrait
qu'ils soient gratuits distribués de
manière là je ne devrait pas y avoir de
sujets sur la question d'accessibilité
financière on le sait pour terminer les
plus précaires sont ceux qui ont le plus
souffert pendant le produit dans la
déchiffre maintenant que les personnes
âgées et les travailleurs clé aussi
souvent migrants qui lui sont morts en
masse pendant cette épidémie il faut
avoir des décisions politiques qui
renforce la protection le des plus
précaires notamment l'accessibilité
financière c'est-à-dire la gratuité du
masque est de mon point de vue
fondamental c'est un outil de santé
publique un outil de solidarité
nécessaire pour lutter contre l'épidémie
et jean françois corty très très
rapidement avant de se quitter on l'a
dit aussi tout à l'heure paris et les
bouches du rhône sont depuis aujourd'hui
aux zones actives de circulation de
virus
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre si les
chiffres continuent d'augmenter à de
nouvelles mesures de restriction je
pense à des fermetures de deux bars de
restaurants et puis il est peut-être la
limitation à 2 de la population pour les
déplacements alors aujourd'hui
effectivement ces deux régions sont en
dit en zone active du virus ça veut dire
qu'il ya des décrets qui permettent au
préfet notamment de prendre des mesures
plus restrictives d'interdire des
rassemblements voire de fermer certains
lieux publics des bars ou autre je pense
qu'on n'est pas dans la situation de
mars aujourd'hui plus de tests on a
meilleure connaissance des gens se les
enjeux de santé publique
ce qu'il faut c'est éviter une situation
où l'on soit obligé de confiner à
l'échelle nationale on se dirige
probablement en fonction des voisins en
fonction de l'évolution des indicateurs
verde confinement très localisé il faut
s'attendre à peut-être der confinement à
l'échelle d'une région de certaines
villes ce qui permettra de continuer une
vie économique une vie sociale l'échelle
nationale dans les temps à de vigilants
et en pouvant adapter vos mesures de
santé publique en fonction des lieux où
l'épidémie est plus active voilà la
vigilance merci beaucoup
jean françois corty d'avoir été avec
nous cet après midi je rappelle que vous
êtes ancien directeur des opérations
internationales de médecins du monde et
vous avez examen est également pardon
exercé en tant que médecin dans un
centre cofide à paris